very good passer sets up keegan murray  and welcome to the nba there you go  keegan cutting and finishing over  selamugbe  [Applause]  spinning on jessup good defense better  offense that was a nice finish nice drop  step  catch and shoot three for keegan murray  i haven't heard from him much recently  murray deeper three still easy range  [Applause]  three-point percentage is rising santos  has 20 points now and keegan murray's  got 21.  [Applause]  [Music]  post up murray ladue gambled and he paid  for it yeah  can you put it on the ground and find  people  o'connell finds murray he's on fire you  have sabonis in fox that you have a guy  that can stretch the court that has some  size it can also help